but ultimately for any film
or tv show or book or any work of art to
have relevance it has to touch you here
it has to move you emotionally um we
love van gogh not because
of the theory of what he's doing we love
ango because those paintings speak to us
they move us
what do you love about star trek
discovery
doug jones i think is terrific
he's the lead in space command as well
or one of our one of our lead actors and
he's absolutely wonderful
i think the production design is pretty
amazing i think the detail on sets and
costumes is pretty amazing the visual
effects are good i think it's it's gone
kind of i haven't watched all of the
third season yet but i felt the first
couple of seasons were pretty weak in
terms of uh just characterization and
and story line
um i you know there's
there's a lot of talent in that cast but
i i would have i would have developed
the characters very differently i would
have um
gone much deeper
i think that there's a very hit-and-miss
quality to a number of the characters
where it's like who are these people and
what what's the point of this story and
i think they're often talking about the
emotion without actually dramatizing the
emotion and um
so i you know a strange new world's
maybe the star trek episode the show
we're all waiting for that's the ones
captain pike um the fun part about that
is captain pike was the original captain
the first pilot that gene roddenbee did
of star trek in 1964.
and so if that and now that's being
greenlit as a show so it's the longest
period for when a show was pitched when
a pilot was made to when they actually
picked up the show it's like 55 years or
60 years that's pretty fun
how do you think gene roddenberry would
have felt about star trek today
i think he would be um have very mixed
feelings i think he'd be very glad that
was still generating
billions of dollars and still popular i
think i don't think he would necessarily
be that fond of star trek discovery um
or picard simply because
they
are missing the opportunity of telling
stories that have
relevance to the current moment you know
i think he was very
very much someone who wanted to
make emotional points that related to
the real world and i think star trek
discovery and picard have been
they kind of have sort of
they're kind of drifting a little bit
you know and uh
it so i don't think he'd necessarily
like those shows particularly
but that's not for me to say
you know ask him when they clone him you
know
what's your argument that star trek is
better than star wars
well my argument is i wouldn't say that
star trek is better than star wars i
would just say that it's different
i you know it's
my friend mel gilden
says the golden age of science fiction
is 13.
and of course by that he means that when
you're a 13 year old that's when you
find those things in science fiction
that really speak to your heart
and the universes you want to live in
uh it's just for me
i remember when i was a kid i recorded
the original broadcast of star trek on
reel-to-reel tape in case the show never
aired again and there were no vcrs
there's no way to
you know record the entire show where
you could watch it
but i remember that week after week
after week there were stories
that i'd never seen anywhere before they
were astonishing and they had such
profound meaning
for my life you know i remember a city
on the edge of forever
where kirk and spock and mccoy go back
to the 30s and kirk falls in love with
this woman who runs a soup kitchen and
ultimately he finds out that in order
for the time
um
flow of time to turn out correctly she
has to die
and
so he literally allows her to be hit by
a truck he throws her into a truck
and
every tv show i'd ever seen before that
the hero saved the girl it was just a
given and in this one
he's responsible for the death of the
girl
and and the message was sometime in your
life
there'll be something you know is the
right thing to do
but it'll break your heart but because
it's the right thing to do you have to
do it
and i was profoundly changed by that one
episode that harlan ellison wrote
and um
and i and and so star trek had a deep
deep formative
influence on me
and whereas i can't say that luke or
leia or obi-wan or any of those
characters as much as i like them
changed me in any way particularly other
than entertaining me for a few hours
so um
so i'm not
i think if someone thinks that star wars
is better than star trek more power to
them i i think it's fine for anyone to
have any opinion basically as long as it
doesn't hurt anyone you know i think
compassion has to be what rules us and
it's it's so liberating when you don't
need to be right
you know when you say this is just my
opinion if you have a different opinion
it's fine that does of course that
doesn't mean racism or misogyny or any
of those things you have to speak out
against things that are really hurting
people but most opinions are just people
having opinions you know is star wars
better than star trek i don't know not
for me but for other people sure it's
fine like when jj abrams loves star star
wars you know i mean
you know i'm sure that he feels really
bad that he wasn't able to uh to do
everything he wanted to do with it you
know so
luck of the draw
it reminds me a little bit of the keith
richards biography where he talked about
a lot of these jazz enthusiasts and
there were two different types there
were the ones that were sort of schooled
uh in the bars and and had learned to
play yes by ear and then there were
others that had these theories and they
would argue it and
the film world feels like that at times
yes well i have i have very little
patience with theorists you know it's
funny uh you know i think of the
twilight zone companion as an oral
history of the twilight zone i
uh was very lucky that all all the
writers directors producers actors were
alive with very few exceptions i mean
rod serling was gone one of the other
writers charles bowman was gone but most
everyone else was alive and so i was
able to get the direct story from the
people who made these shows who wrote
them and directed and produced them and
the cinematographer and so forth
and uh
but when you have theorists it's like i
don't really want to hear people's
theories i don't care about that it's so
academic and so pointless i would rather
hang out with people making something as
opposed to people commenting about
something and it's funny because when i
wrote the twilight zone companion i
wrote it to learn how to be a writer
producer in television not
and so then when people offered me gigs
to write books about other tv shows i
always said no because that wasn't why i
did that book i didn't do that book to
then write the making of mash or the
making of you know
hello kitty or whatever you know any of
anything you know
my little pony but um
you know so i
and and it's funny because on
dvds and blu-rays i'll always listen to
the commentaries of the directors or the
writers of the film or tv show but when
it's some guy some theorists like he's
the head of the film department at you
know some university and he has this
this theme about alienation or whatever
it's like oh i don't
go away
you know it's not it's not worth my time
and it's not of interest to me
that doesn't mean that you can't have
larger meanings or metaphors or any of
that
but ultimately for any film
or tv show or book or any work of art to
have relevance it has to touch you here
it has to move you emotionally
we love van gogh not because
of the theory of what he's doing we love
ango because those paintings speak to us
they move us
and uh you know so that's the one thing
i do like about the modern age
is authenticity
is valued now so for instance
if people recognize me as an authentic
person and that my work is in alignment
with who i am as a person or the people
i mentor the run the roundtable i run if
everything i do from mr sci-fi to the
round table to space command to all
these things are all
um
in a line they all speak to the same
compassions they speak to the same
kindness
people recognize that i'm authentic in
what i say and do
and i'm very glad that that matters
because when i started my career
the only time someone in the audience
would encounter something of some work
of mine is by reading a book i'd written
or watching a tv show i might get a fan
letter or maybe meet someone at a
convention now
the audience is directly in
communication with me and i actually
like that because
it tells me i'm on the right path
because i know and i don't need
the fans i don't need the fans tell me
what to do artistically
but it's nice to know that what i'm
setting out to do is being accomplished
so it's great
well that's the problem it's people who
are in the ivory tower people who are i
mean particularly
like it's like people who didn't know
anyone who made that film or anyone who
made that tv show it's like you know
some expert on howard hawks but he
didn't know the guy and free and
frequently they'll come up with all
these reasons why something was done
that has nothing to do with why it was
really done it could be they were losing
the light so that's why he shot it as a
one or you know like one with without
cuts you know it might not have been a
stylistic choice and then the light was
gone or you know there's always
things that come out great through the
wonderful
chaos that production is
um
you know you always see the love see if
i wanted total control over what i was
doing i'd be a novelist
because novelists can sit in their
little rooms and the universe can be
exactly the way they want it in their
work and then they give it to the editor
and they can take those notes or not
take those notes
but they're sort of the god of that
universe they create
i love to collaborate i love what actors
bring in my work what what designers
bring my work what everyone brings to my
work i love collaboration because
there's such an element of surprise if
you
choose people who are talented and
brilliant and
passionate the work they come up with
will surprise you when an actor takes a
for instance there was a in the pilot of
space command there was a monologue i
wrote for bob picardo where he talks
about the death of his wife
and when i wrote it
i said this probably won't work
but i'll try it and i can always cut it
out and then bob delivered it and it's
astonishing it's wonderful
and
um
and so i was really glad i trusted my
actors and said okay i'm not convinced
let me see what he can do with it
and he surprised me because he really
went somewhere
truthful
and
you know and that was that was me
partnering with someone who made my work
better
so i have nothing but gratitude